tu as fait cette émission c'est vraiment
avec lui
à tout était avec lui depuis quatre ans
quand tu l'as fait et à la fin des
missions ont été vus avec lui
alors attendons à ce que t'as pas de
micro mouvements qui se passe c'est que
veut le mettre dans le bon sens et là il
est dans le sens qui permet depuis admis
tout
à ses défauts
mais ça je vois tout de suite c'est un
expert
mais magnifiquement fait méritée à fait
merci ah bah tiens c'est beaucoup mieux
ça
donc voilà donc je bouge pas tes fiches
punch au putsch connaît par coeur et là
effectivement dont quatre ans avec
brandon et ce qui se passe avec brandon
mois la plage c'est que tu découvres que
l'île de la tentation mais qu'est ce qui
se passe dans le combat j'ai été tenté
et toula trompetant tata j'ai trompé je
me suis vengé parce que ce que tout le
monde sait maintenant ce que j'ai dit
plusieurs fois puis la main de reprise
ouais c'est qu'un jour avant l'émission
je m'étais déguisé en blonde avec des
lentilles bleues et je suis parti de
griller dans une discothèque il était en
pleine action belle relation de
confiance on essaie déjà arrivé
déterminé et lui fini mais beaucoup ont
fait l'émission c'est qu'elle a c'est
quoi si tu venais je voulais me la faire
à un moment donné le nom m'a dit oui sur
le contrat qu'il a signé il faut la
faire sinon tu as une arme encore comme
aimeraient d'époque j'étais encore voilà
je crois encore un peu bêtes n'ont donc
jamais eu gt gt faire cette émission
mais voilà j'ai mis dans la valise des
petits trains et des maquillages et là
tu te trompe donc pour te manger brandon
pourquoi être que si on a un con tre tf1
mais faut la sortir ces démissions quand
même les mecs autour d'une tasse tient
mais on va rendre malheureux tout le
monde dont la nique et des couples tu
vois si on avait cédé un format secure
qu'un suicide est dedans où tu vas et
donc regarder mais du coup brandon
apprend que tu l'a trompée et pète les
plombs c'est mythique
sous le choc des images brandon enfreint
toutes les règles de l'émission et ses
chats pour rejoindre palmetto le site
des femmes hors de lui brandon c'est
armé d'un bâton et devient totalement
incontrôlable on ne jamais venir
périence j'entends ma femme
c'est des cours avec un bâton il veut
taper tout le monde le single oui à sa
marque et ça m'a vachement marquer mais
comme tous ceux qui regardaient la
regarder la télé réalité à l'époque
parce qu'il faut quand même préciser que
c'était la saison 1 saison suivante elle
savait un peu triché se jouer un petit
peu de tout ça c'était pas du tout le
cas de dire et brandon et là on les voit
réagir le mec est vraiment à cran ils
sont bien la suite c'est quoi vous vous
séparez totalement l'émission s'arrête
en fait c'est la prod a dû intervenir
ouais on voulait tous se barrer en fait
ouais moi j'étais ultra jalouse
amoureuse enfin la malheureuse aussi et
lui la pète un cap ce qu'il se rendait
pas compte de l'amour qu'il avait pour
moi cette époque là quand il m'a vu
embrasser un autre mec ça y est la san
fermo la vrille et moi j'étais
complètement destin est capable de vous
dire écouter une émission n'a pu courir
demain pour n'était pas dans la réalité
quand même quand on est parti faire ses
missions aujourd'hui tu me dis va la
faire saisir et non c'est quoi ton
métier avant leur soumission j'étais
dans quad à l'époque j'étais si fier
d'eux
non pas être au boulot en fait c'était
coiffeuse à journée
il était plus strip teaseuse parce que
c'est là où on est venu me recruter
forcément donc vous vous égarez comme
l'eau alors qu'est ce que c'est parce
que du coup dans la rue par dompter ses
liens à caqueter la méchante et c'est le
cas car on dit un homme malheureux non
c'est qu'une fois que non 1 figure toi
que ce n'était pas la méchante parce que
les femmes sont venus me féliciter
pourquoi est ce que j'ai dis haut et
fort que j'avais été la plus grande
qu'au cul de france ouais et où les
femmes se sont un peu reconnu
en fait j'ai fait une petite vengeance à
va 1 fleur c'est pas non plus j'ai fait
une petite vengeance et lé les femmes
étaient avec moi j'ai les pieds sur
l'utile bien monté à trouver où elle a
été vraiment montagne à quelques petits
trucs il y avait quelques petits trucs à
un moment donné je rentre dans une pièce
on est quatre deux garçons deux filles
et je rentre avec un jeu de tarot pour
jouer aux cartes acca à quatre personnes
le montage est fait aux je rentre
qu'avec un garçon il faut le jeu de
cartes que va-t-elle faire à la semaine
prochaine avec sept garçons et puis
c'est du côté de caunes rien ne dit rien
il voulait c'est le champ libre
complètement ou est-ce que y avait quand
même des petites suggestions tiens et
c'est d'aller le voir dans la pisse
alors là va faire un tue-moi match et me
connais assez pour savoir que je ne
gagnerais non non non à ces morts c'est
à dire que les choses n'ont pas bien non
et combien le faire à dos carré cannes
c'est non et après c'est combien passer
tous et
et c'était aussi que c'est con mais à
l'époque la grecque n'était pas encore
connue et quand on des faits ça je fais
rue est d'accord je faisais ce que
j'allais auto disait on tourne et c'est
léger on me dit c'est comme l'interview
on te fait en temps et un mètre sur est
bien s'orienter j'en ai rien à [ __ ]
des mois je m'avançais un petit peu la
suite agressé quoi qu'est ce que tu fais
après tu fais les anges alors je fais
des photos qui viennent de la fédé 10
des livres des films des machins chant
plein de choses tous attendent et on met
à peu près toute cette histoire de télé
réalité c'est qu'on y arrive on ne sait
pas à franchir quelques appartements
voilà
non mais dis moi la ville non mais dis
moi des montants cent mille deux cent
mille
noms comme s'il y avait des mois je
voulais faire 200 des fois cinquante
mille euros c'est quoi raison à l'époque
qui avait pas tout ce qui est agréable
tout ça a même posté les euros libre
donc ont enregistré 2 080 vite sa lutte
et bien sûr diana
ouais ouais entre ça et c'était quoi tu
veux un mot coquin avec diana tu as fait
ça parce que ça m'a apporté beaucoup à
l'époque les six magazines c'était du
trente quarante cinquante mille euros à
l'époque oui
qu'est-ce qu'elle avait donné deux
minutes à gagner quoi tu penses à
millions d'euros si on met tous qu'on
aura plus fin mais combien russe en un
an quand même j'ai gagné plus riches y
voit la douane on dit pas moi nous dit
le site 2 millions 3 millions oui en
fait les choses en main et ouais mais
oui bien quelqu'un ma vie mais je te
dire qu'est ce que la touche ok encore
plus je vais te faire débat n'a plus
rien je pouvais faire une couverture de
magazine à 40000 euros ouais et le soir
allaient travailler mon restaurant
menway taggia marité travaille jamais
très bien senti c'est en fait c'était
diana lachy connu et nadia mon
personnage qui travaillent jusqu'à sa
voiture diana jones sinon celle du bogie
pas bon du tout c'est nadia comme nadia
nadège et gianadda rolala nadia la nuit
et diana le jour
le jour je vais pas gagner des millions
est donc très investi dans les ports
millions animal dans l'immobilier ce
qu'à l'époque j'avais envie d'amour et
un resto mais j'essaye d'écouter des
apparts partout en france un petit peu
tunis
et casey mais non ce que je veux dire
quoi là c'est que
j'ai dit franchement j'suis pas toujours
acheter un sac à 400 mille balles wef a
lui demandé mairie non moi dans ma tête
400 commandes au web voila ca n'a pas un
mais quatre cent mille balles chez les
mouches anciens francs non
les émissions mais mathieu un sac à 400
millions euros je connais pas
c'est vrai bilan critique pas ces mamans
mais bien sûr qu'il n'y a pas eu et
c'est charles ces zélés de bonheur parce
que moi j'ai tourné avec toi tu as eu
une prise de poids gigantesque était
très malade j'en ai pas parlé à l'époque
parce que je sais que les magasins bien
et y croire mais j'ai eu des cancers
j'ai vu deux ou trois années de merde
j'ai disparu de la circulation
mais j'ai eu la chance de rencontrer un
fan qui m'a rendu très heureuse qui
étaient là pour moi qui ai toujours là
dans ma vie et je vais même vous dire
autre chose je suis plus heureuse
maintenant que j'ai pris du poids parce
qu'on me regarde plus comme un comme un
steak ou très belle robe noire comme une
femme normale et je suis bien et le fait
de travailler ça me donne envie de
revivre de de côtoyer des gens vrais
parce que du sang par les gens parler de
ça tout à l'heure sur les sur les ovins
faille parler de ça sur les voir les
enfants n'ont pas tous d'accord sur les
abeilles ses compagnons disait
effectivement oui c'est pas assez pas
juste une fois quand tu as été diana de
l'île de la tentation une bombe et que
tout d'un coup bas tu peux pas dire j'ai
eu un cancer et que les courtisans qui
prend soin tu prend 50 kg et que dans la
rue les gens te juge te regarde vers
l'est ce qui est arrivé katy perry
autant ça doit être horrible arguments
font ça ne me touche pas mathieu juste
d'autant plus qu'il faut rappeler à pour
ceux qui découvrent diana aujourd'hui
que c'était une énorme star à l'époque
donc là on parle d'argent comme si
c'était de l'argent qui tombait du ciel
non elle le méritait parce que moi j'ai
fait à l'époque c'était une marque de
déodorant qui l'a emmené chez moi si tu
te souviens tout l'été sur un bateau
rail où elle faisait la tournée des
boîtes de nuit moi j'allais avec elle
jeudi un journaliste qui suivait tout ça
et madonna contre et en guadeloupe
c'était une énorme
madonna mais un peu le déodorant
n'importe quoi de fait beaucoup mais
après vous fera vous l'ont fait tous ça
m'apprend fini mais tu as bien raison et
maintenant mais heureuse tu habites où
j'habite à marseille tata buts à
marseille tu as des appartements terre
entière terre entière abdelilah
site de la télé réalité quand même
sur terre battue en ce sens band des
beatles sans vent l'eau du bain tendon
de toutes ces conneries juste parce que
tu as bien investis à cet excellent
l'eau du bain regardez ces as du coup tu
veux le faire j'ai essayé de sauver un
peu mais bon non non pas de mal non non
non c'est pathétique claude nobs
wallach et laurent et anne so qui sont
les patrons j'ai travaillé au club des
pages entières
m avait alors scellé mort entière peut
d'abord oublier terre entière tu me dis
oui j'ai pas compris ton monte vite
c'est à bruxelles s'est dite loi
je travaille dans un restaurant je suis
responsable de baho club vacances et
pourquoi qu'ils étaient des appartements
et le consol energy arrêtera permettra
jamais de ma vie je me prenne chez pas
de
nom